das beste ist hallo mein name ist luca
und meine lieben zuschauer ich war mal
wieder in den youtube trends unterwegs
und habe dabei dieses video hier
entdeckt leben mit tourette die
verrücktesten geschichten dieses video
wurde hochgeladen von dem kanal gewitter
im kopf leben mit tourette und falls
sich einige von euch jetzt eventuell
erst mal fragen sollten hey was ist
eigentlich tourette tourette ist eine
erkrankung des nervensystems und leute
die an dieser krankheit leiden machen
oft einfach aus dem nichts heraus
irgendwelche bewegungen zu können und
das heißt dann ticks in der fachsprache
und dieser tag kann sich nicht nur in
irgendwelchen bewegungen äußern sondern
auch im sprachlichen äußerungen sage ich
mal also in beleidigungen etc der kanal
gewitter im kopf wird betrieben von zwei
personen und zwar von jan und tim tim
übernimmt er eine moderierende rolle
sage ich mal in den videos und jan das
ist er hier
er hat tourette teilt sich den kanal das
erste mal entdeckt habe vor einigen
wochen als das sowie den trends war habe
ich mich im ersten moment gedacht hey
die berichten vielleicht irgendwie
theoretisch über diese krankheit und
klären ein wenig auf was sie auch tun
und das ist auch sehr sehr sehr sehr gut
die machen das ganze allerdings nicht
nur sachlich fachlich sondern auf die
unterhaltende art und weise und das ist
megageil
bevor ich euch ja allerdings jetzt noch
weiter voller aber darüber was auf
diesem kanal eigentlich passiert aber
ich habe ihn euch auf jeden fall auch
unten in der beschreibung verlinkt also
check den kanal gerne aus dass dort
gerne ein abo da und jetzt starten wir
mit der heutigen reaktion
ich fühle mich irgendwie ein bisschen
schlecht darüber zu lachen aber es ist
halt einfach unterhaltsam und witzig
wenn er gefragt wird sehen wie und dann
irgendein wort mit c sagen soll wie
clown und er hat sagt halm
bitte versteht dass wenn ich jetzt hier
lache dass ich mich in keinster weise
über irgendeine person hier lustig
machen möchte ich schätze die arbeit
unfassbar dort und ich finde es mega
geil was sie auf die beine gestellt hat
und was sie gerade auf youtube alles
erreichen ich meine die zahlen sprechen
für sich aber es ist halt wirklich
lustig wenn er halt zwischendurch
einfach irgendwelche wörter rein ruft
die einfach überhaupt nichts mit dem
thema gerade zu tun haben
verläuft die krassesten pharma-lotto red
geschichten die das habe ich auch schon
herauslesen können er sagt immer pommes
ich weiß nicht wie oft er schon im
restaurant pommes bestellt hat obwohl
das gar nicht wollte resser menschen die
an der tourette krankheit leiden
allerdings sehr häufig und zwar dass sie
einfach wirklich ein spezifisches wort
haben was sie einfach kontext los sehr
häufig einfach sagen und das ist bei
ihnen dann halt anscheinend zum glück
ist das jahr findet ein oder andere mal
ganz interessant zu wissen was alles um
schlimmstenfalls passieren können das
was er ihr nebenbei macht sind keine
grimassen sondern das sind dann halt
diese tipps wenn man beispielsweise
irgendwie mit den augen zwinkert oder
seinen kiefer verspannt oder mit den
händen liegen wir um fuchtelt ich würde
sagen wir vom land will was passiert
wenn man das ganz kurze info gisela ist
keine dritte person irgendwie im bunde
die jetzt gerade in der kamera sitzt
sondern gisela ist der name den er
seinem tourette-syndrom gegeben hat hat
mich vor diesem video ein bisschen
schlau gemacht sage ich mal mehr oder
weniger über das tourette-syndrom und
das machen wohl anscheinend auch sehr
viele tourette erkrankte dass sie ihrer
krankheit einen namen geben damit man
sage ich mal besser mit der krankheit
umgehen kann ich weiß ja dass jetzt
gerade hier zu dem thema passt
allerdings hatte ich ja lange zeit
während ich halt praktikum ohne youtube
alles nebenher ablaufen lassen so
bernard erscheinungen panikattacken
herzrasen herzrhythmusstörungen und
dieser krankheit habe ich auch im namen
gegeben kilo das ist mein zweiter name
und da das eine krankheit in mir drin
war die einfach so zwischendurch hatte
ich auf einmal herzrhythmusstörungen und
dachte ich sterbe gerade dann habe ich
mit mir selbst wirklich laut geredet hat
gesagt kino kommen soll so ich weiß
nicht ob das gerade irgendwie sinn
ergibt aber ich glaube so ähnlich ist es
dann auch mit der tourette krankheit
einfach um damit besser umgehen zu
können
das um dann die sprachlichen äußerungen
ja also in der zeit wo ich mir dann
einen neuen ausbildungsplatz suchen
musste hatte ich überall diverse
vorstellungsgespräche und schriftlichen
einstellungstest und dazu bin ich aber
auch schon mal ein städte gefahren in
denen ich nicht bekannt würden bzw
am tourette-syndrom bei den örtlichen
bankfilialen polizist nicht so bekannten
[ __ ] das fand ich gerade krass und
zwar wirklich fast eine halbe minute am
stück geredet ohne irgendwelche tipps zu
haben das hat er einem anderen video
auch schon mal erklärt und zwar auch
wenn er beispielsweise auf englisch
redet hat er gar keine ticks das ist das
finde ich persönlich sehr interessant
von daher falls ihr noch mehr über diese
krankheit tourette-syndrom erfahren
möchtet oder falls ja auch fragen
vielleicht an ihnen habt dann checkt auf
jeden fall deren kanal aus also mein
heutiges video jetzt gerade soll
natürlich eine reaktion auf das video
leben mit tourette die verrücktesten
geschichten seien allerdings möchte ich
euch mit auch ganz ganz klar auf diesen
kanal aufmerksam machen
bitte lasst bei denen ein abo da weil
ich finde es mega geil die informieren
über die krankheit aber machen sich
quasi über sich selbst ein bisschen
lustig auf eine sehr humorvolle und
nette art und weise und das ist einfach
mega geil wollte noch geld abheben und
dann bin ich da in eine bank ja da
reingegangen hitler mörder aber was ich
mich da frage wenn er doch theoretisch
irgendwo rum läuft beispielsweise durch
eine fußgängerzone oder so und er
schreit dann irgendwelche wörter raus
ich glaube das könnte wirklich
unangenehm sein wenn man allein
unterwegs ist tourette hat und irgendwo
ist wo einen keiner kennt jan macht das
schon krass ist auch echt ein großes
vorbild was heißt oder so für sachen
wenn du eine bankfiliale dann ist ja
verschiedene sachen oder also in der
regel so überfall banküberfall geld ja
das soll jetzt nicht falsch rüber kommen
aber ich glaube wenn ich auch gerade in
dieser bank gewesen wäre und irgendwie
allem automatisch länder und mit geld
geholt hätte und dann kommt höre ich auf
einmal von hinten sondern stimme
irgendwie geld her banküberfall
ich wäre im ersten moment wäre ich
glaube ich auf dem boden gegangen und
hätte echt angst gehabt also eine frage
die ich an euch habe vielleicht seht ihr
das video hier gerade tim und jan wenn
ihr oder wenn der jan zumindest er hat
ja tourette wenn er unterwegs ist um
dann beispielsweise in der innenstadt
oder in gefüllten räumen irgendwas sagt
entschuldigt du dich dann direkt sage
ich mal dafür beziehungsweise erklärt
den leuten dann das tourette hast und
dass nichts passieren wird oder wie
gehst du davor sie das ist was was mich
interessieren würde [ __ ] fliegen da
hatte ich halt meine hände so in den in
den taschen drin und habe ich mit einer
hand so getan als ob das eine waffe also
mittags aus und dabei haben banküberfall
das habe ich zum beispiel nicht also die
situation jetzt gerade ist dass er in
eine bank gehen wollte sich geld abheben
wollte und dann hat er die bank gegangen
ist hat der tig und das habe ich auch
gelesen das ist wie so nießen also wenn
man kurz vorm nächsten ist dann kann man
es ja auch nicht unterdrücken bei ihm
ist es dann scheint so dass irgendwas
sagt und das sich direkt unterdrücken
kann und was er gesagt hat ist halt
banküberfall und hat aus seiner
jackentasche sondern hand pistole
rausgeholt
geld her juden und ich hatte irgendwie
einen knopf drücken und das in der
region polizei sonst kommt aber richtig
das hat dann konnte er das richtig
ansehen ich habe dann aber direkt
gerufen dass ich hab's tourette und das
ist kein überfall
ok dann hat sich meine frage die ich
vorhin anja angestellter falls er sich
dieses video anschaut hat sich dann ja
schon mehr übrig unter dem tresen diesen
knopf können da draufdrücken und dann
kommt halt direkt polizei weil das wär
halt krass gewesen die frage ist halt
dann auch wer die kosten getragen hätte
weil eigentlich kann ja nichts dafür
also er kann jetzt eigentlich nicht
haftbar dafür gemacht werden das habe
ich auch gelesen dass denn leute halt
irgendwie andere leute beleidigen und
man zeigt jemanden an der tu red hat
dann wird die anzeige zurückgezogen weil
er ja nichts für die text kann ich
feiere diesen kanal übertrieben das
haben wir zehn jahren extra mit
bonn bei einer bankfiliale haben wir
sagte das für euch mal zeigen wollen wie
das aussehen könnte das tun wir jetzt
hier mal einen mixer
die wahl zusammen in einer bank und
haben das ganze gefilmt ich hätte mir
nicht aber gespannt über hitlers twix
also ich glaube dass es dass sich die
tics also ich kann es natürlich nicht
beurteilen weil ich selber kein streit
habe ich glaube dass sich die pixeln
situation indem man nervös ist oder in
besonderen situationen das sind da
vielleicht sogar öfter zum vorschein
kommen bei mir mit meinen panikattacken
jetzt ist halt auch so dass es in
einigen situationen krasser ist und in
anderen situationen überhaupt nicht
vorkommen beispielsweise wenn ich
morgens sport gemacht habe am tag über
gespielt habe und ich so ein mega stress
hatte dann habe ich das halt gar nicht
also meine letzte panikattacke die ich
habe hatte ich glaube ich märz im monat
her und wenn ich halt beispielsweise so
das ist jetzt natürlich der extremfall
schlechthin aber wenn ich drei tage lang
auf dem festival war alkohol konsumiert
habe wenig gepennt habe und dann voll im
stress sachen gepackt nach hause fahre
dann vorprogrammiert dafür dass sich
herzrhythmusstörungen kriege herzrasen
und atemnot et cetera pp also ich glaube
es kommt genauso wie bei panikattacken
auch bei tourette so ein bisschen auf
die situation gerade an
ich habe drei geld okay zum glück
zensiert es musste
doch richtig an schreit seinen pin das
ist das ist natürlich unglücklich in der
bank genau jetzt habt ihr mal gesehen
wie das aussieht wenn der jan eine von
vielen jahren daran geben weil ich finde
dass ist im video noch so ziemlich haben
das war also es kann auf jeden fall
deutlich übertraf
also ich meine die sachen ja auch selbst
darüber aber ich möchte jetzt einfach
noch mal sagen ich mache hier keineswegs
über die person ich will mich auf keinen
fall über die krankheit lustig mache das
ist eine sehr ernstzunehmende krankheit
aber es also ich glaube das ist die
richtige art und weise wie man mit
tourette umgehen sollte es gibt ja auch
videos auf youtube compilation die über
zehn millionen aufrufe haben so tourette
krankheiten einfach wie leute irgendwas
rufen leute beleidigen et cetera da habe
ich mir auch schon immer gedacht hey
okay das sind jetzt irgendwelche
compilations und leute finden das witzig
und bla bla es ist halt einfach eine
krankheit
das will ich leute die wissen hey ich
mache etwas lustiges und dann kommt
vielleicht auf youtube sondern die haben
halt tourette und ich finde dass dieser
kanal gewitter im kopf wirklich das
perfekte beispiel dafür ist wie man mit
der krankheit umgehen sollte
beispielsweise bdl ish die hat auch
tourette glaubt die meisten leute
wussten dass gar nicht williams oder
weil ich habe keine ahnung wie sie genau
ausgesprochen wird die hat aber meines
wissens nach glaube ich nicht diese
coppola lee die der jan beispielsweise
hat und zwar diese coppola hat dieser
hang dazu
so drang coppola ließ einfach eine
neigung zum aussprechen von
beleidigungen obszönen wörtern et cetera
pp allerdings möchte ich jetzt gar nicht
mehr weiter auf dieses video hier
reagieren wir haben uns zwar erst vier
minuten von den 14 minuten angeschaut
und die erzählen noch weitere
geschichten die der gern mit dem
tourette-syndrom schon erlebt hat die
sache ist allerdings dass ihr euch dass
er selbst auch anschauen können hier
findet einen link zu dem video und zu
deren kanal und noch einige
informationen zu dem tourette-syndrom
unten in der video beschreibung verlinkt
also check das gern mal aus wir bereits
gemerkt habe wollte ich in diesem video
gar nicht so doll reaction auf das video
jetzt das komplette video anschauen
sondern ich wollte euch viel mehr auf
diesen kanal aufmerksam machen
ich glaube die meisten leute werden dann
allerdings eh schon kennen ich meinen
die jungs haben über eine halbe million
kapsel nicht mal zwei monaten gemacht
das muss man erstmal schaffen dort auf
jeden fall mal in die video beschreibung
da findet ihr den kanal von den jungs
verlegen abonniert die gern mal das den
gruß von mir da ich glaube die wohl noch
in der nähe von köln
also irgendwo bonn oder so in der ecke
also falls ihr bock habt mal auf einen
kaffee vorbei zu kommen oder offene
pommes dann würde ich mich sehr freuen
und dann sollte ich das heute wieder
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben freunde
ich hoffe ich habe das video hier
gefallen wir uns das getan hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch da schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare
ob ich noch auf ein weiteres video von
den jungs reagieren soll weil ich finds
auf der einen seite mega cool dass sie
informieren über diese krankheit agieren
aber auf der anderen seite sich selbst
nicht allzu ernst nehmen und immer noch
für unterhaltung sorgen aber hätte da
die wir auch vorbei
[Musik]